going out by the chair of the Health
Committee for Health Secretary Jeremy
Hunt you saw him there what did you
learn this morning well I think we
learnt some very important new bits of
information first of all that the virus
has now moved from the contained stage
to what the government calls the delay
stage the second stage and they are
doing very active preparations for the
final stage known as the mitigate stage
and what that really means is that we
have got to get our heads around the
possibility of potentially 20% of the
population getting this virus that's the
level of penetration in Hebei Province
in China the epicenter of the virus and
so the governor is having to make some
very difficult decisions first of all
they say this morning they're going to
bring back they're going to allow
medical students who ordinarily wouldn't
be able to operate as doctors until they
qualified if they're in their final year
they might be allowed to practice as
doctors and first-year foundation year
doctors also would be allowed to do
things they previously might not have
been allowed to do that's a very
significant step and some big debates
going on inside government about school
closures as well do you think the NHS
can cope with 20% of the country getting
coronavirus well no Health System
anywhere in the world can cope with a
pandemic in a way that means it's
completely business as usual and
professor which he was very open about
the fact that there may be some impact
even on urgent treatment we asked him
what it would mean for example for
cancer patients but what he said was
that the the impact at his height would
be for about three weeks and so if you
get the timing of that three weeks right
if you're able to predict accurately
when that three weeks starts and when it
ends then you can do an enormous amount
to make sure that urgent treatment is
protected either because it happens
before that or because it happens after
that
but yes there are going to be you know
impacts particularly for people who have
pneumonia and respiratory diseases where
the pressures will be at their highest
it doesn't help though does it that that
we have 43 thousand fewer nurses in the
NHS
we need what we do need more nurses we
need more doctors that's the only long
term where we're going to reduce the
pressures on the NHS the government's
got plans for that but I think it's
important to say that you know the scale
of what may happen means that there's
going to be pressure in health systems
all over the world and most people look
at the NHS in fact there was an
international study an independent study
done by Johns Hopkins University amongst
others in the United States that said
that the UK had the second best prepared
health system in the world for dealing
with pandemics and most countries that
don't have an NHS would think this is
one of the moments when it's very very
good to have one but the government is
now changing its policy towards nursing
and students isn't it it's it's funding
5,000 more student training places it's
giving nursing students 5,000 a year to
help get staff to come back in do you
accept that cutting bursaries when you
were in charge was now an error well I
never wanted to do that and I I fought
against it but I was told by the
Treasury if I wanted an extra billion
for the NHS that was going to have to be
part of the deal so I'm very pleased
that policy has been changed and you
know we have increased nurse training
places by a quarter there are the plans
for 50,000 nurses these are the only
long-term wave that we're going to
reduce pressure on the NHS front line
it's more doctors and more nurses but
the vacancy rates are still really high
15% and London 16% for some mental
health units that's why we we urgently
need these new 50,000 nurses that the
government's promising what what are you
doing to protect yourself from
coronavirus well I'm listening very
carefully to the the advice I'm not a
doctor myself so I'm listening to what
the the doctors are telling us and we
heard some very important information
from Professor Witte at the Select
Committee hearing that for example the
virus can potentially survive on a hard
service for up to three days it's
unlikely to survive that long
so it is incredibly important to wash
your hands when you arrive from work or
when you arrive home at the end of the
day if you've been on public transport
and you know catching your sneeze in the
tissue thinning the tissue washing your
hands regularly these are the things
that will have the most impact in
slowing the spread of the virus what
about travel have you cancelled any
travel plans well I was due to go to a
conference in the United States this
weekend
that was actually canceled by the
organizers and I think there are gonna
be all sorts of short-term impacts that
we start to see obviously people are
very worried after the news from fly B
this morning and I know that the
judgment call for the government is how
you minimize the economic and social
disruption whilst always making sure
you're taking the decisions necessary to
save people's lives why do you think
that our government's view on things
like closing schools is it's so markedly
different from Italy's well they are in
a different phase of the virus it's it's
much more advanced initially than it is
here but we had a very good discussion
at the Select Committee this morning
about that and this is now a live issue
for ministers to decide and the reason
that it's a difficult judgement is
because coronavirus doesn't seem to
affect children as badly as vulnerable
older people but it seems like they can
catch it and pass it on so in that
context you might want to close a school
to slow down the spread of a virus but
if you do that you're then
meaning-making
meaning that mums and dads might not be
able to go to work because they've got
to look after children and some of those
mums and dads could for example be
doctors and nurses who we very much need
to go to work in the NHS so it's a very
difficult judgement that ministers now
have to take or indeed it could be the
grandchildren and have to look after the
children and don't hunt good to talk to
you thank you very much Jeremy Hunt
sorry good to talk to you thank you
thank you